buenos días así es han sido
cuatrocientos noventa y tres días de
negociaciones hasta formar un gobierno
es decir un año y medio en que varias
veces han estado al borde de la ruptura
pero aunque bélgica está bastante
acostumbrada de hecho tiene un récord ya
en 2011 en que tardaron más de 500 días
en formar al gobierno el nuevo ejecutivo
está liderado por un joven político
alexander de croo de 45 años pero que ya
es conocido aquí en bélgica porque como
comentaba si había sido el primer
ministro del anterior gobierno ministro
de finanzas y también ministro de
cooperación y de desarrollo de hecho
justamente como ministro de cooperación
en múltiples ocasiones había había dicho
que él era un ministro feminista que
estaba a favor de la igualdad entre
hombres y mujeres y justamente cuando
donald trump retiró la ayuda a los
países en desarrollo por la
planificación familiar
alexander de croo junto con el gobierno
holandés fue uno de los que promovió una
nueva plataforma para ayudar a las
mujeres en estos países además dentro de
la coalición se va a introducir un
concepto nuevo en el código penal de
feminicidio algo que no existía hasta
ahora y forma parte de estas
negociaciones tan intensas estar
contanos cuáles son los retos que tiene
por delante el nuevo primer ministro
lo cierto es que este gobierno no lo va
a tener nada fácil porque tiene va a
tener una durísima oposición por parte
del partido nacionalista flamenco
incluso también la otra derecha que
aseguran que este gobierno es totalmente
legítimo también está la lucha contra la
pandemia bélgica ha superado las 10.000
muertes y además los contagios no paran
de subir en grandes ciudades como
bruselas o amberes